like I get a sense immediately my radar
picks up I got five maybe ten minutes
here before we start real and that's
when I go in so the action doesn't
really mean anything to me I'm already
in by the time the director says action
I'm there so wherever I gotta be I mean
I can get ferocious on set like I can be
ferocious and loud and emotional and
like I don't give a what people
think like honestly because you're
getting into it you don't give a
Cruiser men are taught not to put their
hand in the cage anyway I mean so what
the you know and and so this man I
love it
and I just I just go
um yeah I go all the way so by the time
action is said I'm right when action I'm
there with dialogue boom I'm in like
totally in Linda but most of the time I
spend on set is is calm and sociable and
and I'm just you know listening it's
about the homework you know it's about
your homework